he won the hearts of germans even before
he became the u.s president barack obama
was cheered in berlin in the summer of
2008 he was democratic black liberal and
easygoing
in april of 2010 nearly 90 percent of
germans were satisfied with the work of
the american president but after the
news of the nsa scandal broke that
percentage plummeted to 43.
expectations after george w bush were
great but now he's been a disappointment
especially with the nsa affair for
example
i don't think it was his fault or his
mistake
the listening scandal was a low blow
and that obama says he didn't know about
it is absurd
the nsa affair deeply disappointed the
germans close friendship and trust has
become a relationship of mistrust
things looked much different at the end
of 2009 when 78 percent of germans had a
positive opinion of their american ally
the figure is just 35 today
i have a different concept of trust
listening to miracle cell phone wasn't
very good form but it's not enough to
shatter mutual trust we're not talking
about a love relationship here
it's a government that oversteps all the
boundaries that shouldn't be crossed
this type of espionage terror they're
employing is totally unacceptable
the u.s is not going to stop gathering
intelligence and so far officials in
washington have rejected a german
proposal for a no spy deal between the
two countries
you